welcome to this video playing bath or mg
but I ever really terrible loss again
terrible score against them zero not 0.5
that's no good 0.5 out of three yes sir
the really correct score quote can you
copy five maybe I could have done that
my knowledge of move orders and this
line is very shaky hey i just know
roughly that it looks like that I got a
good position in the earlier game with
that okay
mmm not sure what Bishop g5 you don't
want to give me the pair of bishops and
I don't think you want to ok maybe you
can do to go to g3 here
hmm ok then a couple of interesting
tries now be four 94 they are all or
interesting even the captures is
interesting on deform yeah cannot decide
hmm I didn't really take that into
account but it does make quite some
sense of course putting some pressure on
124 okay I'm taking going for that
diagonal be 3 9 p-6 I pawn on d6 s
really looking weak I'm not actually
taking me to wear this is something that
I should be aware of my head okay when i
plant that badly let's focus here heads
focus that it's not looking good at all
hmm
yeah he's not going to take but I can
still enter the primo
Bishop 97 I can they're probably i don't
know that really looks that doesn't look
good who should be six i can take on
a4ai think that that should be should be
ok ok now at least I have enough
pressure 1d4 so that he has to do
something so here I can take their tip
to one taking me towards that too cheeky
probably it is so but if I'm not doing
that what am i doing in this game so
Bishop we're probably here
preventing any rookie sevens it's
actually attacking before which I did
not see didn't see at all okay look
before Bishop b5 is still okay
now maybe this is just about just about
hooding whoa that is hard to believe so
who takes here I love it there somehow
is finding moves over to hold on even
though that wasn't planned of course
okay what am I taking see true
so we have bishops III is really not
it's really a bit too greedy maybe
Quincy six queen age five maybe
maybe queen 85 actually if the river he
cannot really move the rook so that we'd
be seven I could hook f8 one unit 13 do
really like to win this game I never
wanted them to the sky before and it
would probably get me back to 2,400 you
didn't have for a while so r up 23 here
I should look should work whoa oh my god
hmm time warner head is it is dangerous
absolutely check that's really the the
scenario I hate the most yeah they
blunder piece chand then get some kind
of miracle attack out of it so here yeah
probably lost you have to f6 doesn't do
it so I don't see how I can defend here
again step 6 ruge f80 still goes f6
check now that's even simpler yeah there
was no defense I was really in black
resins really weird yeah just blundered
the piece down but i have to do have to
defend this better Bishop c3 oxy ATM and
now probably this is this is so at least
from a practical point of view probably
this is bad my original idea was Quincy
five I can stop I mean okay I went
didn't so what did I do now that this is
losing ok this is the loser move this is
the losing move I have to play so this
end is over and yeah
I didn't I only thought that this can be
covered I mean not covered I can take
them and that ends the game but you can
take there immediately and wins it's not
even a draw something it wins for what
of all things yeah yeah so that's a
pretty straightforward game he gives me
the bees and I don't take the gift
ultimately to win yeah it's really
nothing going on right tickets check
check check it's not leading anywhere
there it's a whole rook so chan so take
here we had queen of eight it's a look
just like that hmm okay that's about
2,400 well if you were in really gifting
away so many points okay thanks for
watching